[Inaudible].
Always teetering on the thin lane between legality and the dark side.
Donald Trump is not a guy who likes to follow the rules to the letter. No,
I mean, it doesn't matter if we're talking about the elections,
the Ukraine transparency with respect to testing positive for the Corona virus
or about his own corporation. Over the years,
Donald Trump has built an image of a successful man around his own unique
personality. He has described himself time and again,
as a model entrepreneur capable of achieving everything he sets out to do,
even if he has to break some established rules along the way I kind of came,
made us capable of turning everything. He touches into gold,
an unbeatable businessman, the best embodiment of American success.
In fact,
this was precisely one of the arguments he used the most during his candidacy in
2016 time. And again,
he promised that he would bring his successful and proven management skills to
the oval office,
that he wouldn't manage the government with the same skill with what she had
always managed his empire. Now, though,
the question that comes up as what is the truth behind all of
these stories?
Because my friends at the end of September, 2020,
the New York times published a detailed investigation,
the analyzes more than 20 years of fiscal information on both the president and
his business network,
it has been the most in-depth research by far that has penetrated the debts of
the business network of the 45th president of the United States of America.
A corporation made up of more than 500 entities.
The results of this research have brought to light a huge collection of lies,
deception, influence, peddling malpractice, but investments,
and more than clear suspicion about the recurrent use of tricks and cunning.
It's totally fake news. And, and this is the important thing.
Not always legally in order to reduce or evade the
payment of taxes.
You see my friends according to information gathered by the New York times,
president Trump,
despite has immense fortune paid only $750 in taxes in
2017, another $750 in 2016.
And for 10 of the previous 15 years, he paid absolutely nothing.
Just think about that.
All of us watching have paid more taxes recently and the president of the
United States,
but that is not all the research also reveals how Trump's finances may be
suffering as a result of the group's massive debt and poor results.
All of this is true.
Despite the fact that many of their properties have become a kind of influence
bizarre that makes money from pressure groups,
lobbies companies are foreign governments that rent out Trump's properties in
order to win favor with the Trump family.
Of course.
We're talking about the president of the United States.
Naturally everyone wants to be close to the president.
Everyone wants to do him favors. And in Donald Trump's case,
that could be as simple as doing business with his companies. There is,
for example,
the case of the Mar-a-Lago club whose income has skyrocketed thanks to Trump's
candidacy revenue from the club's membership fee,
increased 10 fold in 2016.
And that's before the Trump family doubled the fee and January, 2017,
this has allowed the president to reap an additional $26 million between
2015 and 2018.
And of course, this is not the only example we can find.
There are many, many more
America, first America, first
companies.
Legal and administrative problems,
such as Walgreens pharmaceuticals or Atlin engineering company have rented out
space and Trump's properties at a premium rate just when they were having
problems with the administration, even foreign governments like Turkey,
holding and canceling events in a facility owned by Donald Trump,
depending on how things are going between the two countries. But wait,
just one moment, because although these things may be, I don't know, suspicious,
contentious, possibly even controversial.
The truth is that we could come to see them as almost,
almost something normal after all Donald Trump is a real estate
entrepreneur. However,
this is what a tiny drop in the ocean of controversy that the New York times
investigation has uncovered. You see my friends and this video,
we're going to review the main issues that this investigation has revealed and
how they fit with the image that almost all of us have,
or have had with president Trump.
Our intention is simply to bring you closer to the work done by the New York
times. So, first of all, first of all, we need to know where did it all begin?
Where on height did Donald Trump make his immense fortune?
If you're interested, let's get cracking.
The origin of empire.
Usually Donald Trump posts of being a self-made man,
a shining example of the American dream,
a man turned into a money-making machine,
thanks to his superior business skills books.
Is this true? Or to put it another way? How much of this?
Yeah.
You see Donald Trump as the son of Fred Trump, I New York city,
real estate developer,
who made a huge fortune worth over $1 billion in today's money.
So at the age of three president,
Trump was already earning $20,000 each year.
That's right at eight, he was already a millionaire at 17.
He was gifted ownership of an apartment building with 52 apartments.
By the time he graduated from college,
he was receiving $1 million a year from his father.
And that is a figure that only kept increasing Fred Trump meant his son,
Donald and employee manager, owner, banker,
and consultant within the family business with the likely goal of transferring
some of his wealth through salaries and therefore having to avoid paying a gift
tax. He also gave him one loan after another,
without many of them ever being repaid and addition to transferring stock and
property to Donald below its value. Fred put money into Donald business.
He even paid his driver and total,
it is estimated that Donald Trump received at least
$413 million from his father. Oh, my dad gave me,
was this hairline? No,
it would be unfair to say that his entire fortune valued by Forbes at summit
$2 billion comes from him.
His father.
Only his father gave him Trump did what he had always done.
He'd got himself into debt, up to his eyeballs,
hundreds and hundreds of millions of dollars to build his empire.
His empire included real estate assets, such as the Trump tower,
the Plaza hotel,
and Mara Lago as well as speculative investments and the stock market,
a soccer team, Atlantic city casinos,
and even his own air transportation company.
The Trump shuttle incorporated by the end of the 1980s,
Trump seemed like a real King I came back to is who is up to his neck in
debt. We're talking about more than $3.4 billion. Most of it,
and high end dressed junk bonds, a situation. In fact,
the soon after would lead their companies to be involved in a succession of
bankruptcies that would end up costing investors, shareholders,
and partners who had trusted Trump,
some $1.5 billion. Strangely enough,
as we will see Trump came out relatively unscaved.
He collected generously from companies, even if they were not doing well,
diverted funds to other projects and limited his liability through complex
financial structures.
This is how he built what is now known as the Trump corporation. And this,
this brings us directly to another question.
How has Trump fared as an entrepreneur? Why is this performance been like,
did he really become a money-making machine.
Shirts, couplings, everything sold at Macy's and they're doing great.
Number one, selling tie anywhere in the world, ties are made in China, China,
showman, or entrepreneur.
If there was one thing, the elevator Donald Trump to start them,
it was the reality TV show. The apprentice go home, a television program,
which spoilers the contestants competed to develop the best project within a
Trump company or property in the United States version,
a show in which the American tycoon also presented himself as an invincible
negotiator. The best of the best, the businessman who always got the deal.
He said it again and made money. A lot of money.
Of course the reality was somewhat different and that is not just me
seeing it. Trump and self says it, listen to this.
I play with people's fantasies.
People want to believe that something is the greatest,
most valuable and most spectacular. I call it voracious hyperbole.
It is an innocent form of exaggeration and a very effective form of promotion.
Donald Trump in the art of the deal.
It was in the early years of the new century.
When the British television producer,
Mark Burnett proposed the idea of producing the reality show the apprentice at
that time,
Trump was not at one of his high points after several bankruptcies and his core
business, the empire kind of seemed to be falling apart.
We walked around the offices and saw furniture splintered.
We saw an empire crumbling at every turn.
Our job was to make it look like the opposite.
Bill Pruitt producer of the apprentice, speaking to the new Yorker.
However, such a television program would change the course of events.
The apprentice was a huge success and one that triggered Donald Trump's
popularity. According to the fiscal data verified by the New York times,
he errand $197 million during the time he was featured on the program,
but that's not all because his popularity was soaring.
Brands were fighting over each other to use him or his image.
And Trump refused virtually none of the offers.
He got to plug a product or advertise something, hotels, pizzas, cookie sticks,
vodka, board games, colognes, detergents, underwear.
He even licensed his name for a lane of mattresses that bought him close to
$15 million.
And total it is estimated that Trump earned at least $230 million from all those
sponsorships that were directly linked to the enormous popularity.
He had garnered from the television show,
a TV program that basically factored in Trump's portfolio by more than
$420 million.
We are talking about probably the best business deal of his entire life.
Your.
Of course it wasn't just mattresses ties and Kowloon.
We were also other products that were more questionable. For example,
Trump promotes his companies based on Ponzi or pyramid schemes,
sold courses on how to become a millionaire to people with let's.
This is putting it lightly limited resources and even set up a kind of
university that in the end had to close down in the face of numerous allegations
of fraud and a lawsuit from the New York attorney General's office itself.
That case ended up with a settlement for which Trump was forced to pay
$25 million in compensation. A similar thing happened later,
by the way, with a Donald Trump foundation itself,
which had to be dissolved following a lawsuit for misuse by the New York
attorney general Barbara Underwood. So this whole image about being squeaky.
Clean, it turns out that was more than a little bit dirty.
And addition Trump.
Has also has no qualms about associating with people of how's best to put this
dubious reputations. For example, in New York,
he was closely associated with Tiffin.
Areef a former Soviet era official and Kazakhstan whose right-hand man was Felix
setter or Russian immigrate with ties to the mafia and his very own criminal
record,
no matter what Trump would gladly lend his name to the buildings of these
developers, whose sources of funding were somewhat unclear.
I'm sure you can probably get an idea of what exactly was going on.
And the well-known scandal was that of the budget, California, where Trump, I,
his name and image to be used to market and brand a luxury apartment complex.
It was a project that resulted in $32 million just going missing and lots of
fraud allegations against the developers and against the Trump family itself.
Trump is being sued in Mexico for tax fraud in failed real estate project.
Pan-Am.
Anyway, the point is that with all the money he got from TV,
Trump not only put his accounts in order,
but then just as he had done with his father's money,
he repeated the process of destroying everything he had just recouped.
He reissued a lot of debt to take over beg real estate assets, hotels,
and this time golf courses and 11 new golf courses to be exact became part of
the family.
[Inaudible].
That's during the nineties Trump's companies did not make profits. For example,
since the year 2000,
their golf courses have registered more than $300 million in losses.
Another example, their hotel in Washington opened in 2016,
reaped $55 million of losses in just two years. In fact,
among these few profitable assets are the Trump tower and Mar-a-Lago the balance
sheets of the other businesses leave a lot to be desired.
You see my friends, Trump is a great communicator.
He knows how to reach his audience like nobody else,
and has had the ability to take advantage of it to make money off of his image.
But as an entrepreneur and manager, that's another story. In fact,
although Trump's activities go far beyond family money,
there is a debate as to whether or not Trump would have been better off
investing all the money. His father gave him and the us stock market,
the profitability of the S and P 500 over the same period.
It seems to have been higher than that of Trump's businesses.
But I think the best way to get to know the entrepreneurial side of Donald Trump
is to take a look as Tang and it all antic city, and you're ready. Let's go.
The Atlantic city disaster.
Friends.
There was a time when Donald Trump controlled the Atlantic city gaming industry,
Donald Trump controlled three of the largest complexes in the city,
including the Taj Mahal, which was opened in April,
1990 as the largest casino in the world.
Trump finance these operations with a lot of debt,
mostly junk bonds with rates of up to 14% per year of the wait for it,
3.4 billion with a B dollars in debt.
The Trump organization was carrying 1.3 billion corresponding to the three
casinos in Atlantic city. This meant not in 1991,
barely a year after it was launched. It had to declare bankruptcy.
A few months later, it was joined by the other two casinos controlled by Trump,
the Trump Plaza and the Trump castle.
It was the first major bankruptcy of the group.
Trump was forced to give up 50% of his shares to creditors and exchange for
their agreeing to reduce rates onto fair payments.
And this way the casinos could continue operating,
but the problems did not disappear in 1995 faced with an eminent new
bankruptcy,
the New York tycoon and later president of the United States of America created
Trump hotels and casino resorts,
a company that controlled the Trump Plaza and went public through a capital
increase.
The company raised $140 million and took advantage of this to issue another
155 million and junk bonds at a 15.5% interest rates.
From that point on what took place was a management method that many experts
would not hesitate to describe as dishonest and deceptive for the shareholders.
Trump used the $300 million raised by the new company to pay off loans.
He had personally guaranteed.
And that.
Not all one year later,
this company against a backdrop of grand announcements that overtime proves to
be misleading at best.
They carried out a new capital increase and also issued another
$1.1 billion and junk bonds with that money.
The company continued to pay off Trump, guaranteed loons,
even though those loans have better terms than,
than junk bonds with which they were financing the repayment.
He was also given a bonus of $5 million for his get less
productivity.
And the company also acquired the other two casinos controlled personally by
Trump at a price that many care holders considered insane.
The operation ended up in court. Trump also made loans to himself.
And even though the company was going from bad to worse,
he continued to receive a generous payout as chairman of the board.
In addition to a payment of about $2 million each year for using the Trump name
and the casinos. He even had the company rent offices in Trump tower.
And you might think to yourself, well, that's not so bad.
Surely he can give himself a discount, but no,
they weren't at a bargain price at.
All.
And this way, by the year 2000,
the company had lost 80% of its stock market value,
but that was not going to be the worst thing.
The Trump will tell us and casino resort to file for bankruptcy. First in 2004.
And then again, in 2009,
the company never made any money and gradually lost market share.
And it's poorly maintained.
Two hotels could not cope with the competition and total shareholders and
creditors who had trusted Trump lost more than $1.5 billion due to
mismanagement by a company whose actions were taken more with Trump in mind than
the interest of the company, shareholders or employees.
Despite the fact that the president made a lot of money.
He wasn't spared from this disaster either,
but right around the same time and 2004,
the apprentice was launched where Trump presented himself as a successful
entrepreneur who knew how to do business better than anyone else.
You see my friends, this is a story we know about the Trump empire.
One thing, however, must be acknowledged.
Trump has managed communication like no other.
He used his father's money to create a public image that not only allowed them
to do business and make money,
but also to become one of the most admired people in America and end up in the
history books as the president of the United States, of course, along the way,
as you've seen, he left many burnt corporate bodies and many deaths,
and there's WIC Trump as a top notch Schumann,
but a good entrepreneur that is being a bit too generous.
Let's just say that best. It's not clear. Wait,
there's been a lot of talk about taxes lately.
Does Trump pay taxes or does he not check this out?
Paid millions of dollars in tax is millions of dollars of income tax.
Why doesn't Trump pay taxes?
You've seen so far Trump lives on the edge,
if not far beyond the lane for 10 of the last 17 years,
Donald Trump has not paid any federal income tax.
And in 2016 and 2017, he paid only $750.
And the question is, I want, are, can that be well,
there are two reasons. Firstly, many of his businesses,
as we have seen did not generate profits, but losses.
And if you're a business, if you don't make money, you don't have to pay.
And secondly,
because if Trump is exceptional in any way as precisely because he surrounds
himself with good tax advisors,
even if that means not always complying with the law or at least occupying a
decidedly, great area, questionable deductions, fictitious valuations,
and proper refunds payments for consulting that are not well-defined to discuss
taxes and the Trump corporation,
you need to be prepared to talk about all kinds of tax.
Gibberish.
Example. In 2010,
Trump applied to the tax authorities for a $17 million rebates on a report to
the losses from his Atlantic city operations. However,
there are no serious doubts as to whether that request for reimbursement that
was paid out by the way,
was well-funded that operation has been audited by the tax office and is now in
the hands of a congressional committee.
Trump may have to pay back all that money.
Plus a lot of interest for improperly requesting.
Refund.
Another sensitive issue is that of his tax.
Returns. Trump includes a lot of things as deductibles.
They seem to be more for personal than for corporate use. For example,
airplanes, country clubs, his mansions even has hairdresser. That's right.
He pays money for that here.
Virtually everything he is built for is apparently tax deductible.
There is for example, the case of seven Springs,
a huge property of 80 hectares with imaginate,
almost 5,000 square meters and three swimming pools. Well affectionately,
the trumps consider it an investment asset.
So the corporation deducts any expenses incurred by it,
even if it means changing a light bulb, an addition to the mortgage repayments.
However, when it comes down to it,
it appears to be nothing more than another one of the families,
many residencies. And remember, we're not talking about small change here.
That's more than $2 million saved.
[Inaudible].
Another example is with lawyers. Trump has deducted lawyer's fees,
even when they have defended him for personal matters,
which it should be a surprise to no one is not allowed. Anyway,
these are just a handful of examples out of hundreds and hundreds,
which explain why Trump has barely paid any taxes over the last few decades,
all this as the ends and outs of the Trump empire, my friends,
a corporation lent by the 45th president of the United States whose secrets or
rather skeletons have no come out of the closet.
Thanks to the extraordinary work of the New York times.
Our intention with this video has simply been to shed light on the main findings
of this investigation. But at this point, how about leaving us?
Your thoughts about this whole saga and the comments is Trump.
A good businessman is all this tax shenanigans, just fair play.
And really why does he pay for that haircut?
So we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsidered media podcast.
They provided them the vocals in this episode, but were not my dulcet toys.
Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.
[Inaudible].